[تصفيق]
من قناه التواصل مع الجمهور تغمز كيسي
زوجه حاكم فلوريدا
مذيعه سابقه اخرجت من جعبتها ادوات المهنه
الرئيسيه ثقه بالنفس واناقه وحضور عززتهم
بمهاره التواصل مع الناخبين والراحه على
المنبر هذه الكاريزما الاعلاميه وظفتها
بالسياسه لدعم زوجها المرشح للانتخابات
الرئاسيه الامريكيه
التي انتزعت خانه الزوجه عام 2009 احتلت
صفه الحاكم المساعد ومستشاره ديسانس
الاولى التي لا تفارقه مقربون منه اكدوا
مشاركتها في كل قرار يتخذه لدرجه الخوف من
ابعاده عن مستشاريه المحترفين
انها ليست اذكى مستشاري واقربهم فحسب بل
هي سلاح السري
مقابلات ديسانس المختلفه تكشف مدى اعتماده
على زوجته في تلطيف صورته كمحافظ متشدد
فتالقه بفقره الارقام والقوانين تغنيه
لمسه الزوجه بسرد الحكايات الشخصيه وما
تتخلله من مغامره منزليه لرجل العائله اي
الابا المحب والزوجه المتفاني لفته عاطفيه
تفتقدها شخصيه زوجها المحنك سياسيا شعبيه
كيسيدس لا تقل عن زوجها اناقه مثلت زوجات
رؤساء السابقين مثل جاكي كاندي وميلانيا
ترامب وتاثير سياسي تمت مقارنته بهيلاري
كلينتون لتثير التساؤلات حول امكانيه تحول
السيده فلوريدا الاولى الى سيده لجميع
الولايات الامريكيه في حال وصول زوجها
للبيت الابيض طريق لا يزال طويلا اولى
محطاته اللقاء بالزوجه المناسبه او ما
وصفه لسانتيز باهم المص ادفات السعيده في
حياته
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات